Welcome to Google
Developers Hackademy.
This is the fourth and last part
of the Android SDK
introduction course
given by Enrique Diaz,
from GDG Androidtitlan Mexico.
If this is your first contact
with the course,
I invite you to watch it
in order and do the exercises.
Hello. Welcome to lesson 4:
"My first app for Android."
My name is Enrique Diaz.
Remember
that the previous lesson
we learned
about building blocks
on Android SDK.
The goal in this lesson
is to use
the knowledge acquired
throughout the course
to be able to develop
my first real application.
In this final example
of my first app
I won't be doing
any live coding,
we're just going to go through
which are the important
code portions
and we'll then execute it.
Let's enter the package
mx.androidtitlan.miprimerapp
and into the class
MainActivity.java.
In this class we have
two variables:
variable "NO"
variable "YES."
This will allow us
to send which fragment
will be shown
programmatically.
As we can see here,
the two most important
methods in this activity
are "wasIncredible"
and "wasMeh."
Both are for initializing
an activity
and we will also add
the "putExtra" method
to define if the course
was cool or not.
So, in wasIncredible
we are using startActivity,
the method we previously saw,
but we're now adding
the intent to it
as an anonym variable.
We pass it mainActivity.this,
and then, resultActivity.
Besides, we give it a putExtra
and we pass it
a "Yes" or a "No."
Now, by entering
activity_main.xml,
we can see the is
one TextView
and two buttons:
the button with the text
"Incredible" in it,
and the button with "Meh."
This first button
that has "button1" as ID,
contains an onClick property
which is passing
"wasIncredible,"
one of the methods
of MainActivity.
And same thing with button2.
In the onCreate method
of ResultActivity
we can see we're defining
setContentView
with a layout.
Besides, we're creating
a variable called
"WAS_COOL,"
and what it does is call
the getIntent.getIntExtra method
with a key, which is WAS_COOL,
and we pass it a zero
because that's what
we want to define by default.
What we're trying to do here
is saving this control variable
we're taking from the intent.
This way we can save it
and do the validation.
Below that, we create
a FragmentManager
which is this object
that allows us to be in control
of what we add
and what we delete
within an activity
in relation with the fragments.
Then we create another fragment
and we say:
"findFragmentById"
and we pass it a container,
which is part of the layout.
Below we're defining
that the fragment be null,
because that way we can create
a fragment transaction
and we do it as follows:
fm.beginTransaction.
Now, if the control variable
is "YES",
you create a new
WAS_COOL fragment
through FragmentTransaction.add
and you'll pass
two parameters to it:
the container
and what's the fragment
you're going to create.
Otherwise, if variable
equals "NO,"
then you use
FragmentTransaction.add,
again, you pass
the container to it,
but you will create
WasLameFragment.
Finally, you will use
FragmentTransaction
to "commit" your results.
Now we'll see the definition
for WasCoolFragment.
Within the onCreate method,
all we're doing here,
as in previous exercises,
is return inflater.inflate
by passing three parameters:
the layout we want to inflate,
which in this case is
R.layout.fragment_success,
container and then
the false Boolean,
so it doesn't fix it
as soon as it is "instanced."
And the definition
for WasLameFragment
is exactly the same,
the only difference is
the returning value
for onCreateView is defining
fragment_lame.
Now, let's check the contents
of fragment_lame.xml
and we can see it's
a RelativeLayout
with an image.
If we go
to the graphical interface,
we can see it's a kitten.
Let's check
fragment_success.xml
and we can see the code
is exactly the same,
we just define a different image
for the imageView of this .xml.
Don't forget to define,
in MiPrimerApp Manifest,
the declaration for activity,
MainActivity
and for ResultActivity,
just like we see it onscreen.
We'll now launch
the application...
and let's see what happens.
Our application shows
a text and two buttons.
The first one is "Incredible,"
which answers the question
"How was the course?"
And the button below,
which is "Meh!"
"I didn't like it."
If you tap on "Incredible,"
what it does is call
the activity Result,
with the fragment inserted
inside with the image
of "success boy."
Otherwise,
the same activity will show up
but with the fragment
of the "grumpy cat."
RECAPITULATION
In this lesson we implemented
3 very important classes
within Android SDK framework
and we developed
a two-button app
that reacts
upon user interaction.
We've reached the end
of the lesson and of the course.
My name is Enrique Diaz.
Keep on programming!